[Music]
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push away break
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to fight night flashbacks mr
eric griffin good to see you again my
man back again back again uh this one is
a very special episode because this
fighter that we're gonna highlight today
was a close friend of mine he's on the
ultimate fighter season 10 that's where
i met him but i was well aware of him
before all of it i think you should be
on the mount rushmore of uh
mma uh
fighting should be on mount rushmore if
you have four people have hoist gracie
him another two you guys can discuss but
he should be on there because he was the
first
internet sensation that brought just the
common fan yeah i was about to say this
is a name i would recognize everyone
yeah the look everything but i have a
question we're talking about kimbo slice
right aka big ferg but his name is kevin
ferguson yeah which doesn't sound like a
fighter name so i understand why he
changed his name to kimbo slice my
question to you is why didn't you did
you ever think about coming up with like
a fighter name no i mean because brendan
schaab you know what i mean it's tough
it's tough
and when i first when i first got the
bfc they called me the hybrid now this
was before all those
lame cars were out like the prius hybrid
now that so it was cool but then as
technology advanced like the hybrid
wasn't exactly a tough
moniker you know so uh we switched it
switched it to big brown because the the
podcast the final kid that called me big
brown oh
so that's oh that's like no podcasting
was blowing up it's like the song i made
with little now i can't understand i
didn't know that that's what it was yeah
the big brown name came from fire and
the kid cause everyone called me like
brian called me big brown people call me
big brown and then bruce buffer was
announcing brandon big brown i was like
oh this podcast came out of hand so yeah
so but then i never but so then is that
what you were known as in the ufc
uh like how he was known as kimbo slice
no i think you know brendan job yeah no
one was ever like oh there's big brown
right
and thank god so wait so you think
being called you know
big brown reminds me of [ __ ] yes is
better than hybrid uh hybrid was dope at
the time because here's the other thing
you can't give yourself a nickname right
right
that's just a tool move if you could
what would it have been oh man come on
give it to me sick like like what like
brendon jared leto sean
just something real like jared leto
brenda it's all gucci shove
yeah i come out and gucci thank god
you didn't do the name oh yeah but uh
hybrid came from when i was the ultimate
fighter the coaches because the way that
the ultimate fighter works is there's 16
guys and there's two head coaches and
the head coaches draft you know eight
eight fighters and when they're breaking
down tape on me i think they showed this
on the show behind the scenes
the all like dana rashad evans rampage
and all the coaches talking they're
talking about me like god he moves like
uh like a light weight but he hits like
a heavyweight like and then someone's
like he's like a hybrid of these
heavyweights and then the hybrid just
stuck
and that was before toyota was like oh
cool we'll use that
and then i was like oh man these cars
are real gay so
we switched to big brown which is also
pretty gay so
it's it's this isn't about me though
this is bimbo big ferg
so obviously he got he rose to fame
through his youtube backyard fights yeah
yeah now there was nobody more famous
nobody was a bigger personality nobody
was a bigger name as far as fighting
goes in kimbo sled so that was when
youtube didn't have a trillion freaking
people doing podcasts and stupid hate
videos or whatever so now he was you
know uh a big fish in a small pond and
it man did he get traction i think he
was the perfect combination because he
when you think of a backyard brawler in
dade county miami he looked i mean if
you're making a video game or if you're
casting a movie for a backyard brawler
and
freaking kimbo showed up they're like
dude it's two on the nose get out your
bald big beard gold chain that's two on
the nose so just so you know too before
we watch these some of his best uh
backyard brawls
the deal was there's no submissions so
you can't wrestle no submissions and
there's an infamous one where he fights
this cop he actually loses but uh kimbo
gets him in a guillotine and everyone's
like whoa what are you doing you cheat
her but he was gonna beat him and then
this guy he's like a boston cop tough
son of a [ __ ] beat kimbo up but it's
it's rare he lost so let's start with
these what made him famous so he's six
two two sixty fighting big d and this is
actually if i'm not mistaken this is
actually
uh he got his name sliced because he
sliced the guy open i i want to say
sliced big d up right he sliced big d up
and that's how you got the nickname
slice now is this before the ufc no ufc
started 93 in my hometown denver
colorado but um it was the ufc was at
the ufc at the time right
yeah i mean fight in the backyard all
right you know wow just just but these
are great man
baggy shorts oh my goodness just these
boys make these money very prison yard
right yeah and that's why it was just
bare knuckles oh dudes backyard this is
date miami bro it's hot humid oh jesus
christ
this just don't this don't look legal
like the cops could come oh yeah
definitely not legal in any facet like
you the cops would definitely stop this
but kimmel was just tougher look at him
give him give him his chin to punch him
so you're watching this a it's just
alarming because it's two grown men
fighting a backyard in miami but big
boom
that left hook
that's always been kimbo's thing he had
this left hook from freaking god
he was like whoa this is my favorite
the dude is like okay okay i think uh i
think we good
hold up you train
you're training oh man so that's the end
of the fight right
uh no you i think you got while when
he's come on give me a second here man
there's no i love that this guy's it's
like calling your own fouls
you know in basketball
he's going
he called his own timeout i feel like
big d has small hands well this guy's
done like he's he's not good at fighting
yeah he should just be he keeps taking
breaks
hold on man we're near the satellite
system hold back up man we're gonna [ __ ]
out my dish you don't mess up my dish
bro there's no ring it's just like
there's no grass in this yard
there's no grass oh that's it this
fight's over yeah he quit right kim was
just tougher than everybody and he had
god-given talent because he was also
more athletic than these guys because he
he was a stud in high school and
football he had a tryout
his plan was played for university of
miami he had a tryout with uh i forget
which nfl team maybe the dolphins yeah
but you know the nfl was in his damn six
four two six four forty
two forty eight six two two sixty eight
now what's interesting about all this is
as this is going on you'll see well a
mazda doll is in some of the videos
mazda doll's like 16 at the time jorge
maslow so he started back this he has a
long ponytail
is it this fight
like this
yeah so you'll see mazwell pop up from
time to time fergus takes the chain off
always had the hair on top of his traps
as well harry like oh by the way i don't
also i don't feel like he's actually
bald i feel like he shaves it cut it
maybe because it looks like that looks
like wow there's like a big metal
they're just fighting on cement
it's backyard brawl bro
yeah you think they'd find a better
backyard yeah this one has a ton of land
mines in it
yeah the fergus is just tougher but you
watch these it's like and he's he's
rolling with the wow any swole yeah
look wow
quick man yeah man quick
oh see it's dropped there
bro this guy's in some old navy cargo
shorts doing the damn thing wait in the
middle of the summer is the dude in the
white trying to be the ref
oh yeah and all right have they figured
it out that we should probably have
somebody be ref now i yeah and by ref
you mean just gotta kind of hang around
yeah but you'll see a white boy in a in
a uh
a wife beater a lot of times good job by
kimbo there oh [ __ ] i mean he just see
he looks solid yeah he's gotta ask he
got against the wall that's it
but you see you'll see a white boy
this is all hands right only hands okay
only hands first first rule that door
was open and he was going to hit him
inside look at him just whooping this
dude that's over yeah oh somebody call
it call it
and this guy's eyes messed up
oh
oh man this looks dangerous the thing
about when you when you're when i was 12
watching this i was like holy kimbo is a
superhero that guy has a mouthpiece
which is very rare
well i mean because this is this is this
is this is all pride right oh you're
getting clown in your hair
it's done you're already like you know
you know what i mean
like it's like he's gonna get clowned
anyway
now is there anything in kimbo to be
like all right i'm beating this dude let
me not no no i'm not trying to tell you
this is for the streets man and you will
see a white guy with a wife being on his
neck oh his name's icy mike
now this is what's interesting about i
see mike so kimbo and icy mike went to
high school together i see mike as
kimbo's manager when you get to the ufc
and even during these backyard brawls
but i see mike also started uh braziers
the porno site so kimbo while he was
street fighting beating people up was
also security on the porno set are these
guys talking [ __ ] to him through the
gate
like you're getting your ass beat stop
homie
getting your ass beat homie
what's up fam let's take a little break
from me introducing my friend eric
griffin to the wonderful and caring and
talented kimbo slice because i'm here to
talk to you about online security listen
i've always been concerned about filling
out so much personal information online
everywhere you go you order something
you fill out all this information i'm
like man it seems like a lot what can i
do man between my family my business
life
i got enough to worry about i need the
peace of mind with identity protection
but how do i know what protection i need
it's tough to figure out that's why my
friends at all state identity protection
got me covered the best identity
protection from a brand you can trust
ever heard of it allstate they've been
around forever so much of life is
logging on with our digital lives on
your phone that's why allstate developed
an identity protection product that
protects your digital life because
that's just what the world is now all
right with allstate identity protection
they'll reimburse up to a million
buckaroos for out-of-pocket expenses
lost wages legal fees they'll also cover
money stolen from your bank accounts
401ks hsas and tax returns all right at
all state
they have been protecting things people
love for over 90 years not only will
they monitor to help keep you safe but
should identity theft ever occur their
us-based customer care identity
specialists provide expert support
support 24 7 365 days a year we got you
covered man think that identity
protection
with your bank provides enough think
again the reality that most financial
institutions act only after fraud occurs
so you gotta be listen you don't be
reactive you won't be proactive and
that's why my friends at allstate got
you covered what i love about allstate
identity protection is the peace of mind
and covers my whole squad my whole
family friends we're all covered baby
all right so when you think identity
protection think all state identity
protection to find out if your employer
offers all-state identity protection
head to aip.com shop s-h-a-b if not get
a 30-day free trial at aip.com
one last time that's aip.com
allstate identity protection we got your
back
oh wow there's a lot of get out after oh
yeah jesus christ and you only got paid
in cash you're you know the thing i
think about kimbo in these videos is
like to me it's like how quick he is
there's i see mike how quick he is here
you know like
he came away yeah he can't get punched
you know now this is the main event
kimbo slice versus afropuff who looks 22
years old and then big mac
what is he fighting both of them
yeah not the same time right one after
the other oh oh about to say jesus so i
love this backyard oh look at big big my
cats in the wild is that me
cat
uh now this is like okay this is over
let's take this to the docks
now this is on set of dexter yeah just
oh this dude
this this kid has no business speech
yeah it looks like he has no business
and i don't think he realized he was
going to fight kimbo slice he's so
terrified he has some jordan 11's on
which is frowned upon to fight in right
and not even just that i mean the the
jordans don't fit you know what i mean
nothing fits this is an oh oh there's
never any body one of those is gonna
catch kimball hits you with body
sometimes that's what makes him special
in these street fights
look at the footwork man he's just
trying to land one of those big hooks oh
hey oh okay all right you got me
i would rather fight uh on the docks
around the boats than than in the in my
neighborhood you know like i don't see
my grandma if i if i'm big afro where
the [ __ ] his name is i don't see my
grandpa i want to fight in my
neighborhood so i can go home after like
this fair point oh well it'd be better
if nobody sees it but i mean you already
know people are going to see it you're
on some ridiculous
and he's look at this dude his life and
these videos got views at the time this
dude is rethinking his life right now
he's like damn i wish i stayed in school
and played football
oh man he's the dude
the kid looks young how did you not play
football i think everybody needs to
somebody needs to come over and be like
it's done right
no because everybody around they drove
all the way out there and set this up
we're gonna need some more out of you
buddy so you have the bros around me
like come on get up big big afro what's
his name big afro mike big puff yeah but
you ha look come on big puff look at it
his whole demeanor is like yeah his
hand's in his head his pocket like all
right man i think
i think i think i'm good there couldn't
be a more
there couldn't be more passive moves
yeah kimbo you got me homie i think i'm
good man thank you though thank you for
the opportunity uh big man the kimbo
like you done you've done yeah of course
he's done oh and here comes this guy oh
wow oh wow big mac now not to be
confused with big mac off mike tyson's
punch out no no this is like
he looks like the oh the one guy from
mike tyson's punch-out now here's the
thing as you see kimball gets going
higher in these uh dade county rankings
they get in better shape there's
rankings well
dude that's that's a dangerous thing
over there that he could fall on
look at this is like oh my
god eric this is a do you see how
dangerous that metal thing is over there
that he could just fall and like bro oh
my god oh face first into the
asphalt
eric i like this guy counting
and it and it's kimbo's friend
he's got a nose ring in is that a nose
that might be a booger after getting
punched in the face
this dude has done the ultimate dad
shoes those aren't even new balances
those are just this is a train wreck
yeah
i like how eric's concerned about like
uh parts of the boats and stuff them
falling on it hey dude they have nothing
else going on they're in the backyard in
miami fighting each other for money you
know all right you think they're worried
about running into the boat like i dude
eric's like man do these guys have
health insurance after this yeah
man you think they give a [ __ ] he
thought oh
my goodness
i've seen some of these fights they
fight a guy for a rack of ribs this guy
can't breathe he hit him in full-on in
the chest that's it and it's a hook too
you'll notice kimbo has like a really
special hook you're like you'll see
talent there with the hook stop man
you're done you're done bro stay down
leah kimball's ready to go stay down
his boy's just counting look at the big
security in the back oh my god
here's the thing too though here's the
thing there might have been people
watching this
thinking that they could beat up this
guy kimbo no no no this guy the guy that
got beat up by kimbo there might be
people watching thinking this guy's not
tough or whatever but
this this
other guy
he's probably beating up normal people
100
he obviously had some sort of you know
what i mean accomplishment yeah in his
neighborhood
nobody messes with big hernandez yeah
yeah
actually i think his nickname is big
brown you know like he's a digital man
yeah he might be there's a big brown
ain't nobody touched big brown i love
that he said get off of me
kimbo tried to help him up that's yeah
that's the most disrespectful thing he
could do you don't knock me down and try
to help me up
this guy is just like god dawg what did
i sign up for well his problem right now
is like he he should be thinking i need
to get on a treadmill or something he's
probably thinking right now
because you know youtube wasn't big he's
like well at least nobody's gonna see
this
wrong
big brown
oh my god let's stop okay just stop it
i like i like it he's getting okay
all right
he said i'm just warming up man
whoa the camera
that's the moment that made him keep
going is when he was like oh [ __ ] the
camera
people seeing this
oh my god
oh my god just stop the freaking fight
that uppercut to the left hook yeah
this is the this dude just the mexican
zombies mexican zombie
this guy's tough he's like i can't go
out like that and everybody's trying to
tell him is over man he needs his buddy
go dude you didn't land a single punch
yeah let's get a taco truck out here for
him now
yeah
and what's amazing too is kimbo never
broke his hand like street fights people
break their hands all the time never
broke his hand nothing this guy's got a
concussion he for sure has a concussion
um i mean
damn this dude just dreads yeah so they
uh they had trouble with names back then
huh
yeah i don't know it was just like
whatever you whatever your hairstyle is
that was your yeah i don't know afro
earlier yeah
this was dredged yeah i don't think
thumbnails does he fight does he fight
fade and high top yeah
you know big bulb come on man big balls
just dreads yeah no they because there's
illegal they don't want the real names
out there i assume
but all the cops love kimbo so he was
fine
he was a super star man superstar
everywhere he went
everyone respect him
tap out made a kimbo slice t-shirt
oh damn dreads yeah it looks worse when
dreads gets hit because of his dreads
yeah
you just see every shot and they're not
tied up the fact that you have to do
this yeah every time you're fighting if
you have to go like this when you're
fighting oh
jesus oh
damn dread that's it
even kimbo is like dude
and it's not like bare knuckle fighting
where they have like kind of their hands
taped it's just
hand
you know i wonder if he's still getting
something you okay look at kimbo
that dude ate an uppercut so he's up he
broke his nose no insurance nothing yeah
you had to take him down to the oh yeah
help me up man because back home this
girl's like god damn what happened to
you
i like it i like how you he took the
help
hell yeah he took that look at it he's
like he's like a drunk white girl so get
my hair see it sally get my hair
kimbo get my hair
the legend of kimbo now that only has
208 000 views i'm sure there's bigger
ones
let's take another little break covering
the whole journey with my friend kimbo
slice
because guess what man you know those
times when you're in the zone right now
you're just just there man you're
focused you're productive that's what
the experts call being in the flow state
now what if i told you you could get in
that flow state with a little pill for
my friends that on it we're talking
about alpha brain it's the best way to
get there all right we're talking about
world-renowned nootropics right it's a
supplement with over one billion dollars
whoa one billion i'm just kidding
one million bottles sold a billion would
be insane nobody's gonna believe that
but a million is still a lot kids all
right and listen whatever you're looking
for alpha brain promotes cognitive
functions include memory mental speed
and focus can help you remember names
who remembers anybody's name that's not
your family or friend all right and you
can zero in on the tasks you need to
complete my boy joe rogan says it helps
him form better sentences when he's
talking you think that guy knows a thing
or two about talking yeah man alpha
brain contains amino acids plant
compounds that promote the brain's
release of alpha waves alright which is
associated with greater creativity and
productivity we got you covered man
listen
if you don't like caffeine right if you
don't like coffee or energy drinks
because making jittery alpha brain is
caffeine free and you can try it out man
and listen to this not only can you try
alpha brain out if you don't like it you
can get your money right back just give
them two weeks if at that point you
don't feel like alpha brain is a fit for
you
you're wrong but that's fine just tell
us why and we'll refund your money on
the spot no return necessary so if you
want to try some out for brain baby you
want ten percent off go to onit.com shop
that's
onit.com or go to your local walmart
so i ask you would you rather go to your
local walmart or would you rather just
use onyt.com
and avoid walmart all right that's
honest.com
you're welcome let's get back to my boy
kimbo slice
so then we go from that so now he's
actually well
the hype around him was so massive and
such like a culture figure that
eventually the big boys came calling
because like hold up if we should get a
fraction of these views on ours and this
is before the ufc was huge so then he
starts coming in fighting the big boys
so then he fights uh tank abbott so he
had one pro fight he actually submitted
the guy with the guillotine and then
tank abbott it's his cage side he calls
out tank abbott now tank abbott was the
original kind of bad boy the ufc he was
a guy looks like he's a hell's angel
just [ __ ] tough as they come and
kimbo calls him out now tank abba is a
far cry from dreads yeah yeah i'm gonna
say he hasn't really fought he didn't
see him he fought like me big mike
yeah and was like who else wants
something yeah yeah
and then 10 cabin was like
i'll do it yeah but you know tank
abbott's a little you know long in the
tooth at this point but still legit
threat so this was like kimbo's first
kind of test against a guy who's
actually being awesome
also with rules and uh you know there's
techniques you're supposed to follow
with this right yeah i mean tank i have
a legend man he came up with tank with
uh tito ortiz like he's a monster man
hit like a mack truck look at him jesus
it looks like a hell's angel oh he's
enforced for the hell's angel yeah like
legit threat man this is elite xc days
these were fun man
so there's
there's no jiu jitsu going to be seen in
this fight huh you could do it but not
from these two that's what i'm saying
yeah not from these two it's not exactly
their forte and what's going on with his
chest here he shaved it because he did
have all of it you know like that thing
all the way up to his neck but he shaved
it and wanted to show you the the
black widow tattoo yeah but he only
shaved some of it it's kind of weird
yeah
and then there's i see mike in the back
again they had the triumph
sponsorship yeah so this is the first
time he's finding a guy who's actually
paid to fight and not an uber driver on
the side yeah and you'll see but you
don't think those guys were allowed to
drive uber that that's a by uber back
then i mean yellow cab
but you see like
he's still quick though he quit but oh
my god god dude oh god damn
but this validated kind of all the
people who discovered kimbo early on
they're like that's our guy see he can
do it to even these guys
and most of us well some of the guys
oh look at kimble's trying to tell the
rep yo man get your hands off me yeah
he's wobbled man get up you're trying to
get away yeah you trying to get hit too
but kimbo hit like a mack truck man
what is this ref doing
with his mouthpiece came out and kimbo
gives a flying [ __ ] about a mouthpiece
he fought a dude on the of the docks of
a boat for god's sake get out of the way
you're trying to tell the ref stop
touching me
yeah this who is this ref
he's trying to keep it professional yeah
but it's like dude well also get out the
way yeah yeah yeah keep it professional
also tank is kind of all over the place
too two new knee braces ooh
see kim was just touching him lighting
his head oh oh that would have that
would have been the one uppercut to the
whoa
god
he's damn he got tank looking like
dreads yeah man yeah tank looking like
tonk you know i'm not gonna you know
what i mean
he beat the [ __ ] on and there's i see
mike right there with all the chains
that's his boy manager
this gives all his fans
tank just looked up he said get some
help
he [ __ ] went down on the crowd
oh man oh look even he went up onto the
on to the thing you know
oh yeah people that jump up on the hill
you did that have you ever did that yeah
i did that i would beat mitrione i
jumped on the cage and they say they're
gonna find you but they never do [ __ ] oh
yeah
it's a fun time all right it's a good
time and it's it's pretty high up there
it's about you know seven foot tall yeah
so you fall it's a nightmare
but if if you can't hang on the cage and
without falling off probably shouldn't
be in the ufc
but tank has some problems there man
oh
and i don't know why is he left-handed
is kimbo left-handed i don't think so oh
cause he just has a really good hook i
just felt like he could have so many
times he could have clocked him with a
right hand and he didn't see i think he
stopped there because kim with him in
the back of the head we can't hear it
but i would assume
yeah
come on back up back because in daycare
that's legal but
in the pros you can't hit the battery
actually there was a rule book out in
dade county
there was not
beside you know what besides no
submissions no wrestling right oh oh but
wow that was the hit right now tank was
you know one of the toughest guys ever
do it but he's also in this fight
obviously long in the tooth and he's uh
he's leading with his head which is a
bad idea with uh well i mean he's he got
he's two on eight the guy's got a lot of
girth on him dude like he's always been
a big dude yeah i'm talking about this
guy this guy's just fat now a kimbo no
the other guy okay
he was leading me he's always been thick
oh he's he's always been a thick boy
super thick yeah yeah that's just all
right so this is where it gets dicey
positive for me mike
so kimbo goes on and he's an elite xc
and he's getting some of the biggest
numbers ever i'm pretty sure this fight
was the most watched fight ever at the
time on national tv as far as mma goes
it's the most watch fight ever on live
tv this song like nbc or some [ __ ] like
that with elite xc
kimbo's supposed to fight an another
legend so he beat tank abbott who's a
legend he was originally supposed to
fight ken shamrock
shamrock is mma royalty he's a ufc
champion you know so that was and his
background is not striking it's
wrestling and submission so it was a bad
fight for for kimbo but people want to
see him against the wrestler so
they line him up ken shamrock they put
all this promotion into it
when they're backstage some guy comes
out and goes ken chomp ken shamrock
suffered an i-cut while he's warming up
for the fight the fight won't continue
we're trying to find another opponent on
the card
it's very ufc 279 we're like wait what
he said
to that yeah
so he goes
they go okay ken shamrock suffered a cut
uh warming up backstage he's unable to
fight which there's been some conspiracy
theories where
ken shamrock didn't want the fight he
wanted more money whatever happened the
fight didn't happen so then they go who
else is on the card that is the same way
he does kimbo or similar weight there's
a guy named seth petruzzuli well seth
petrozuli is a actual like his thing was
he's always kind of a like sometimes the
lights would be too bright for him he
wouldn't show up but he was the most
talented guy in the training room so if
he does show up you got [ __ ] problems
but his record wasn't great so anybody
any hardcore that knows mma when they
announce
kimbo slice versus seth petruzzuli
everyone oh i don't like that but most
people don't know seth are like oh cool
i'm gonna watch kimbo destroy this guy
to rogan's credit he's on tv i think
he's in a green room when this fight got
announced before it happens
brogan goes cause he's hardcore like me
rogan goes oh that's a terrible idea
kimbo is gonna get knocked out kimbo is
still a huge favorite in this fight
watch what happens
and for kimbo too you know huge fight
everybody's tuned in switch it you
switch the opponents at last second yeah
you're fighting a younger guy more
dangerous guy
you were going to fight an old guy and
ken shamrock who's you've been getting
ready for a grappler who you know not
known for a striking you're finding a
guy who's pretty well-rounded the first
time kimbos fought a well-rounded guy
you know just the same ref that's a lot
it's only one ref
and the lead xe there isn't apparently
well that's what this is that's how you
know phones went around back then looks
like that guy has a camcorder
so kimbo's going out there to take his
hat off
but he comes in just like every other
fight and gets clipped and then boom
beats them
about eight seconds
now a lot of people are like oh this is
such a huge upset but again people that
know the game are like that was a
terrible idea by kimbo to take that
fight man
what i'm saying is like wow why is why
was the fight over like that
i mean he got clipped wasn't defend
himself first ref called it though right
yeah i mean if you like keep going it'd
been a nightmare okay seth didn't do
much think this so you honestly think
that kimbo couldn't recover from that no
we got way worse from him who took way
more punishment because seth could have
just keep teeing off him he got worse
and worse and worse
but for kimbo think about change of
plans man but he probably but i think
that he thinks why'd they stop this i'm
sure yeah and did they have a rematch
no oh that's too bad because i think in
a rematch you would have been a tough
fight for a man you think so even even
though he said it was just more
well-rounded and like you know training
with some savages
it was just a bad idea by the way
it was a bad idea by the executives that
elite xc to go uh on a four-hour notice
let's give them seth petra zooley who's
a way better striker i just don't get
why they'd even do that no you're
diminishing your product your product
and this guy was the biggest name by far
in the lead xc by far so kimbo rushing
like it was day counting gets clipped
right when he rushes in the kick boom
see that
oh right back go back i didn't see it
because i was looking at it i couldn't
he shows like he throws like a kick like
a sparring kick keep it right and then
hit them with a straight left boom right
on the chin okay right here see kimba's
coming in see the kick watch the kick
here then watch the boom right hand oh
wow oh that that took him down yep
didn't seem like it was a hard punch
and now he doesn't know how to get out
of this no and he right now he's all
over the place he's
he's on six straight
you know when you see it when you see it
like that in slow-mo then then you see
it now you see it but that was just fast
see see the kick then what's right hand
boom
oh you wouldn't think he had harder
but kimbo is coming the problem is kimbo
is coming so all his momentum is coming
into the gotcha so it makes it worse
gotcha got you guys you know and then
see and do things out here do you think
that this is what happened there was
lack of training oh yeah well kimbo's
thing is you know he's a backyard
brawler right so you're dealing with
well it's just a different set of skills
like he had skills but also kimbo is not
young right now kimbo's 30 something
here like mid-30s
so
you know he's getting away on just
throwing these hooks and when you fight
a guy who's seen that can navigate
through that kimbo was against uh you
know the odds here man he was a fan
favorite but you know he's never gonna
be ufc champ it just i feel like that
was like a i don't wanna i don't wanna
say uh
i mean i think there was just like
lucky circumstance in that situation
that he got timed that he got that hit
in when he did yeah because i don't know
if this fight i think it's a different
fight i'm not saying the guy other guy
was going like kimbo was going to win i
would have been more competitive yeah
yeah
yeah i think there's a lot going on with
kimbo there too you know it's like
split decision you know like
elite x he's like hey we know you're
getting ready for an old ken shamrock
here's a young seth petra zooley and
he's like what don't let people down so
then now here we go so uh as as kimbo's
career goes on right he's in the lead xc
and then it's not announced so i get um
the invitation to be an ultimate fighter
10. and the way the ultimate fighter
works is they bring in 16 kids there's
two coaches so we're all there and my
boy mitrione's there and we're talking
and i'm looking around i'm counting and
i'm like there's only 15 people here who
else is here like we're missing somebody
and so we're all waiting and we're all
trying to decide uh i think roy nelson's
like yeah it's some special guest like
they're bringing some special fighter
into the house and we're like oh and at
the time
there's a lot of talk that fedor
emilienko from uh pride was gonna come
to the ufc so all of us were like it's
not fade or is it i have three fights at
the time i i have three [ __ ] fights
but but i thought in my head i'm like
there's no way it's fedor but then when
i see roy nelson who has whatever 27
fights former world champion i'm like
well if he's here
he's a seasoned vet i have three fights
matt has two i think he lied he only had
one the rest of us only have like three
fights so roy's the only one with the
experience
they i think it might be fatal so
obviously oh man it's fedor and so we're
all whispering it's fedor it's fedor
it's fedor and then dana's like now
clearly there's only 15 of you right
we're missing one guy and then he goes
and remember we're thinking it's fedor
and he goes kimbo come on out and so
kimba walks in
all of us thought it was gonna be fedor
so when kimbo walks in this is how the
the nation met me for the first time i
go oh [ __ ] kimbo
and they i forget we're mic'ed up and
they even subtitle it [ __ ] tim though so
be like oh hell no [ __ ] this brendan
chubb but you just gotta realize i'm
thinking it's fedor walking through the
door i'm like i'm [ __ ] i'm not he's
going to destroy me so when kimbo
there's a sense of relief i'm like oh
[ __ ] kimbo but i didn't know him at the
time i assume he's the backyard brawler
and when he comes in the house you're so
the way the ultimate fighter works is
you train twice a day then you're in the
house you can't do anything else no cell
phones no books no newspapers books
brendan nothing
nothing
nothing even if you want to upset about
that i can't bring my book
my boy justin wren who's you know super
religious couldn't have a bible like
they don't like nothing we made our own
like uh trading i'm sorry cards like to
play like [ __ ] pokers they they threw
those away they cut them in half so they
want they'll give you all the alcohol
and food you want but nothing else so
you're forced to be around these dudes
and all you're doing is training and
fighting each other so you live with
even the guys you're fighting you all
live in the house together so you're
around each other 24 7 for six weeks
straight and that people break up in the
packs just like anything
and me and kimbo
got so close in that house because
kimbo he looks like you know looks like
a backyard brawler from dade county was
the nicest guy you've ever met man and
he would uh they would allow us to order
anything you want and come the next day
so kimbo always ordered these steaks and
burgers and he could grill his ass off
so when he was at the grill and i like
grilling two
he would always make this special sauce
for everybody eating his food and it was
like the best barbecue sauce you ever
tried it was like a regular barbie sauce
mustard honey and put something else in
it and i always ask him what it is he's
like can't tell you man it's kimbo
secret recipe so then as we get more and
more to be friends
i didn't have tv or any form of
entertainment so i go to kimbo to tell
me old school stories because remember
he was security for braziers he was the
the main security for all these porno
shoots so i'd be like oh what's it like
man he'd tell me all these crazy stories
about the porno stars he talked about
fluffers like kicking crazy boyfriends
out who were mad their girls were doing
it so he was better than tv so i mean
him got really close man and i felt bad
for him because again he's older and he
was just a you know a brawler man and
yeah
the ufc is full of killers and
he was taken advantage of yeah big time
and then he also like he you could tell
he like
he knew he was against all odds but
there was no arrogance or anything like
he'd come to me or roy nelson because me
and roy and uh yeah roy and i knew
jujitsu he'd come to us at even in the
house like hey man can you can you teach
me the butterfly guard or can can you
teach me how to get a guillotine choke
so he's he was aware that was his you
know deficiency so he's trying to like
figure out some so he was so humble such
a nice guy and then uh the last week are
in the house i made to the finale he
ended up losing earlier which we're
going to watch now but i was in the
finale and i told him i said hey man we
get out of here we'll be bawling man
because the biggest ultimate fighter of
all time most watched show of no one
will ever touch it's the most watched
ultimate fighter hands down because of
kimbo not me
or roy it was just because of kimbo
everyone's tuned in for kimbo so kimbo
would always make that barbecue sauce oh
dude what if you and i opened up a
barbecue joint called slices barbecue
he's like oh i love that so that was the
plan right why was your plan well he
passed away oh kimmel died i didn't even
know that yeah i had a bet hit a bad
heart and uh he was on the list you know
how it works like everyone's looking for
hearts and he couldn't
get on the list fast enough in his heart
he kept having problems yeah didn't i
don't i didn't know that yeah it's
tragic tragic yeah i love kim and his
son's uh you know still alive and
carrying on his on and he fights in
bellator little slice we call him yeah
he's a great kid you should start to
barbecue the thing with him he doesn't
honor him you know what but kimber
passed away didn't tell the sun the
secret recipe so we're [ __ ] we're
[ __ ] we're [ __ ] and nobody will be
able to enjoy that barbecue now so this
is interesting so
the way the ultimate fighter works is in
the house again there's two teams so i
was on team uh rashad and there's team
rampage kimbo was on team rampage i was
on team rashad and so is roy nelson me
and roy were on the same team and then
we fight you in the finals
so before the fights
the coaches get together with dana white
and just and tell them the matchups and
then they record it whatever
i went up to and this again is before i
knew kimbo i went up to rashad and went
give me kimball i'll just i'll mop the
floor with this dude whatever you want
me to do i'll stand with him i'll take
him down this is easy work it's gonna be
the biggest fight of the season i'll
destroy this dude rashad goes you're
right you're gonna fight kimbo i said
hell yeah dude and i'm like this is my
big breakout moment
everybody's gonna watch this that was
the plan
they go in to do the
to tell dana the match and all that
stuff and then rashad come and i go not
my call man it's roy nelson what the
[ __ ] you took the fight for me it was
out of my control not my call to having
roy nelson fight him well i found out
later on that the ufc didn't want kimbo
to succeed so they wanted to make sure
he didn't win in the house now roy
nelson is a guy where the moment why i
think because he doesn't come from a
traditional background because and i
think they completely missed the mark on
this i think they royally [ __ ] up the
situation i think they should have
done anything to get kimbo to the finals
to make the ratings bigger than ever but
their plan was let's show them that the
ufc is a professional league kimbo is
this backyard brawler so let's give him
roy nelson who's been in big fights
fought in world championships the
moment's going to get too big for him
and he can just take him down and if he
does get clipped he has a granite chin
me i only have three fights like with
shaub yeah we think we can beat him but
there's a chance kimmel can win so like
we want to take no chances give him roy
nelson so roy nelson again that's how
the credit to kimbo roy who's fought the
who sue andre
ben rothwell before this he fought
everybody he was scared to get hit by
kimbo slice so he just takes him down
puts him in his infamous crucifix and
pounds him away and so roy i'm sorry
kimbo loses his first fight in the house
which i think was a huge mistake by the
ufc huge mistake and because he lost
then he was taken out of the house no if
you lose you still got to stay in the
house
that's where it gets interesting
[Music]
there's going to be a worse matchup for
kimbo like you know because roy a cracks
like a [ __ ] cannon out of his right
hand trust me on that but then also
he's a black belt jiu jitsu and can
wrestle so you know he's throwing jab
but you just get putting him on the back
of his head what a sneaky
this is a sneaky thing this because this
guy doesn't look like much
right boy you can imagine you in a bar
thinking like you know trying to talk
smack to this guy and he's you know
oh
but like because if you had to pick
between these two
if you were going to say to yourself you
didn't know these two you don't want to
mess with
you know you're not picking the bad guy
the fat guy ever with a belly button
that's deep enough to do you know but
do people know like if but if you knew
his background like right that's what
i'm saying that's what i'm saying
jiu jitsu yeah
canon for right arm that's why you know
phenomenal cardio like great cardio
that's why don't mess with people no
dude he's the lizzo ufc like you be want
to make fun of lizzo's car don't [ __ ]
dude she's on rollerblades [ __ ]
dancing for two hours and per like she
has cardio man
roy has cardio
full circle so this is white lizzo right
here
you said it not me
i'm a fan of lizzo
but this fight was so intense because
also on the ultimate fighter there's no
crowd wait pause it real quick for me
so i should say this there's no crowd
but the the ufc employees and then also
the commission but
they because kimbo is such a big deal
he's getting paid on a different
contract than we were because kimbo
slice kimbo is allowed to have his
family and friends at the fight
so his manager i see michael absolutely
adore and his his girl and some his
other friends it was like it was dade
county they're and they're we hear this
chair i'm like who in the [ __ ] and i
look i'm like oh they're with kimbo but
no one ever like we get it obviously
he's bringing the ratings go ahead and
play it
we can hear everything but you'll hear
the fighters really aren't talking
because we were like so curious what was
going to happen here because you didn't
really now all of us did train with
kimbo because in order for them to
decide who's going to get drafted number
one through eight you have to train with
everyone so you get a sense you get to
me and kimbo sparred together we
wrestled together we did jiu jitsu
together so you kind of know what if you
ever get hit by him i did
yeah he hits like a mack truck man but
look at him even here roy nelson dude as
savage as they come
and he's you know for for his lack of
expense here was to to to to get
to get him killed
100 because if he didn't do that he
would have a chance
yeah
coming around dude
but this is the this guy's tactic is to
do this right i mean he dude he takes
everybody down
and when he does it's a nightmare to get
up from him of course because then it's
all this girth on you now he's there
girth but he knows how to use it he's a
very very high level that's what i'm
saying that's what i'm saying like the
guy he's bad enough just being whatever
260 pounds but he was like dense and
then he also noticed how you use his
weight it's a nightmare man yeah he's
got his lower belly is actually keeping
you know what i mean it's a nightmare
it's like on his body like he you know
helping to keep him down i mean it's
like he's using ever he's just he's
using all of himself he really is
now he did take me down and i did get
back up not a big deal he won the fight
though this isn't about you right it's
not about me i'm just saying he's tough
to get up from the kimbo kimbo slideshow
this is not the big brown
show but kudos to kimbo like dude this
guy has 30 more fights than him fought
the hoot ben roth monsters doing ifl you
know was on a championship team in ifl
and he went on to just destroy some
dudes in the ufc big boys kicking his
leg that sucks
and so he gets them down eventually and
then this is to kimbo to be fair it's
like
you know you're talking about a white
belt versus a elite black belt on the
ground like you're [ __ ] man and again
this was all so is this like a
submission move you just because i do
this to my girl you know what i mean you
just
kind of
you're just on it
but you see like roy's just slowly
methodically just wearing his ass out
and kimbo just the way his hands are the
the he has no clue what he's doing down
there and to his credit it's like he's
still fighting though man yeah yeah
i mean this is like i mean how much i
mean this is you know what i mean this
is a lot you know
see so this is roy's
classic move see how he pinned your hand
down yeah and then pins your other hand
down yeah between his head
oh yeah use it use the cage kimbo's just
look at that bro look at that not
knowing what you're doing he could have
broke his neck right there though
you know what he'd rather break his neck
doesn't carry through with this like you
know he's just it's just demeaning yeah
but this roy did this to a lot of people
man a lot of high level people who also
are black belts on the ground imagine
being kimba at his age kim has bad knees
all he can do is really his box think
about the the bravery of kimbo slime
still get in there is this the famous
move right here this is it yeah we'd see
how they're not defending they probably
should stop this but he was atlantan
enough
like that's herb dean and he'll let you
go some
look roy's talking to him like he's not
even fighting back man
but they're not big punch so he makes it
out of the round which again kudos to
kimbo slice dude
because if if this was a regular ufc
fight and fans were allowed to vote on i
bet kimbo is a
plus
1500 you know what i'm saying he's nate
diaz hamza
it's not it's an awful matchup for him
but again uh roy's the perfect matchup
because a granite chin so if kimbo does
land he's not gonna knock him out roy
was impossible to knock out until he
fought mark hunt and then you know on
the ground he's a nightmare so it's the
perfect matchup to ruin kimbo slice see
land there most people without knockout
kimos landed on roy nelson man
and this is my thing this is where the
ufc missed the boat dude let this guy
let the guy flourish
don't don't ruin the biggest star
but again the ufc is probably hoping oh
if roy beats him he'll get the shine
there and roy's actually gonna have a
long career in the ufc so they're
probably thinking that
because you could bet on roy because
he's already had 30-some fights at this
point
there he goes pin it again
jesus
it's probably like this for another two
minutes mike
another minute
because he's just methodically just
breaking him down until he gets that
to gets the
i just it was a shame because but also
once kimbo lost in the house he still
trained with everybody he still worked
his ass off still made barbecue for all
of us he was great i mean
is this him if i was that famous i'd be
like i'm [ __ ] out i mean this is like
the belly smother move like you know if
you've got like your belly like it's
just all his weight but look how he
pinned your arms so you can't protect
your face and then once you can't
protect your face they're gonna stop the
fight so he might not be
destroying him here but
just there's no point there's no point
he could just go on he could do this for
three minutes yeah right right right
he's just heavy on top even kimbo has no
really clear what he's doing down there
and but to be fair kim you know kim was
not
injured his face isn't [ __ ] up
it's just yeah that's one of these
things that was like you can't you we
got that's that's equivalent to like a
submission yeah same thing he's not
doing this no ref is going on the
website we've had enough get out of here
wow
yeah so that's and that was so dana
always said though we're not going to
allow kimberley in the ufc he's a
backyard brawler and then dana or i
think it was actually kimbo's idea goes
well put me on the ultimate fighter let
me earn my way to the ufc and he did
earn his way so your contention is you
believe
that dana white
did not want kimbo to
advance in the ufc correct
correct and you feel that he they
actively held him back
and tried to sabotage his career 100
100 there it is and then he so then he
still gets into the ufc but by uh via
the ultimate fighter he gets in the ufc
and then when he's in the ufc again he's
older he has bad knees so he fights like
houston alexander which wasn't a great
fight he had a few losses he had some
fights to give him matt matrion which is
a nightmare for a guy who can kick in
his bad knees so i just felt like they
were never supportive of them where it's
like man you've ruined a guy who was
such an influence such uh should be on
the rush mount rushmore of [ __ ]
fighters man i just felt like they could
have been nicer to kimbo slice yeah
it's a bummer man well
you know
still talking about him so yep you know
he's nice and peace my man yeah he had a
good he had an influence on the sport uh
his legacy lives on and you know
when i get now you know a little more
about kimbo slides yeah i mean i this
like i said i i i
feel like
this is so much more than just sort of
barbaric brawling oh yeah because if
you're like an outsider looking at the
ufc or just sort of fighting you know
this sort of com com combat sport you
you you would kind of think of it like
that and i've said that publicly in the
past was just too violent for me but as
i started to like do these things with
you and and just sort of like watch
there's it's this sort of like you know
physical chess game that's being played
big time but you can see too like the
admiration people should have for kimbo
slice coming from that backyard brawling
background being older mid 30s by time
he really starts fighting professionals
like he has some big wins man he beat
james thompson who at the time was a
savage he beat houston alexander savage
david abbott savage he ended up
beating ken shamrock bellator finally
put that fight on he tko'd him so it's
like to half his experience and so he
was like five and twos i was saying one
yeah five five and two yeah that's he
was gonna raise the extra winning record
yeah that's pretty good yeah not bad
that's pretty good uh well i mean i
think it was limited i think it was more
than just just the fighting i think that
what he also brought
i think he brought something that the
the ufc took from him this idea of
a personality being the thing
yeah 100 and i think also what people
are surprised by too is he wasn't this
uneducated like
thug like he was like caring like a
great dad like that's why when i talk
about kim when asked me to do like a
tribute to him on spike like i started
crying because
kimbo was so misunderstood because you
see him on youtube and he's his backyard
brawler yeah yeah yeah yeah
gold mount teeth you know all that [ __ ]
dude great dad such a good dad cared
about his kids that's actually why he
started fighting because he couldn't
continue on with football he was living
out of his car and was like i need to
make money man i have this [ __ ] left
hook from god let's see what happens
look where it let him dude it's [ __ ]
dope it did for his kid man so i'll
always uh always hold a special part for
kimbo slice man i love that dude yeah so
eric hope you have a little more
appreciation for your people i do this
is like i never i yeah
i did i did not know and now i know so
there you go thank you guys for watching
fight night flashback that's eric
griffin i'm brendan schaub that was
kimbo slice tune in next time see you
guys